JOHN BOLTON AND MICK MULVANEY.
>> Jason: THANK YOU.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
READYING ITSELF TO MOUNT A
POWERFUL DEFENSE IN THE SENATE
SO WHAT'S THE BEST ARGUMENT FOR
TRUMP AGAINST HIS IMPEACHMENT
SHAM?
OUR NEXT GUEST SPENT THE WEEKEND
GOLFING WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
JOINS US EXCLUSIVELY.
TREY GOWDY THE FORMER
SOUTH CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
SOMEBODY I WAS ABLE TO SERVE
WITHIN THE PREVIOUS CONGRESS.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
I HAVE A PICTURE OF YOU GOLFING
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
CHECK OUT THIS FORM.
THAT IS QUITE THE SWING.
GREAT BACKSWING.
IN THE BACKGROUND, YOU CAN SEE
THE PRESIDENT LOOKING OFF INTO
THE TREES AND BUSHES TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE THE BALL WENT.
>> THERE IS A 50% CHANCE OF
GOING LEFT AND A 50% CHANCE OF
GOING RIGHT.
THE ONLY PLACE YOU NEED NOT LOOK
IS DOWN THE MIDDLE OF THE
FAIRWAY.
>> Jason: YOU ARE A PRETTY
GOOD GOLFER.
GETTING SERIOUS HERE, ARE YOU
GOING TO REPRESENT
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMING INTO
2020?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS GOT GREAT
LAWYERS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
THAN HAVING GREAT LAWYERS, HE'S
GOT GREAT FACTS.
I THINK FOR SEVERAL MONTHS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE PROCESS
AND HOW FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED
IT'S BEEN.
IMAGINE BEING INVESTIGATED BY
SOMEBODY LIKE ADAM SCHIFF.
THAT'S THE PROCESS.
JASON, I FOCUS ON THE SUBSTANCE.
THE SINGLE BEST PIECE OF
EVIDENCE FOR THE PRESIDENT IS
THE TRANSCRIPT ITSELF.
YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE
TRANSCRIPT.
THIS IS THE SECOND PHONE CALL
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY HAD.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP WERE OBSESSED
WITH CONDITIONING AID ON
INVESTIGATIONS, HE WOULD HAVE
BROUGHT THAT UP IN THE FIRST
PHONE CALL, RIGHT?
IF YOU ARE REALLY OBSESSED WITH
IT, YOU'RE GOING TO BRING IT UP
EVERY CHANCE YOU GET.
PULL THE TRANSCRIPT FROM THE
FIRST PHONE CALL.
NOT A SINGLE WORD.
LOOK AT THE REMAINDER OF THE
TRANSCRIPT.
WHAT DO THE PRESIDENT SAY?
HE SAID I WANT YOU TO DO US A
FAVOR.
FOR THOSE WONDERING WHO "US" IS,
HE ANSWERED IT.
HE SAID I WANT YOU, OUR COUNTRY
HAS BEEN THROUGH A LOT.
THE "US" IS LINKED TO THE
COUNTRY.
WHO BROUGHT UP RUDY GIULIANI'S
NAME?
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY?
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY INTRODUCED
RUDY GIULIANI INTO THE
CONVERSATION.
THE ONLY THING PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID IS HE INSERTED BILL BARR.
IF IT'S AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE
TO ASK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, TOM
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS OF THE
COUNTRY, TO LOOK IN TO POTENTIAL
IMPROPRIETY, IF THAT'S AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE, WHERE IT'S
GOING TO HAVE PRESIDENTS SERVING
VERY LONG.
>> Jason: I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT JOE BIDEN ON THE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SUBPOENA.
TO HEAR JOE BIDEN SAY, DEPENDING
ON WHEN YOU ASK, HE HAS PRETTY
MUCH COVERED EVERY NUMBER ON THE
BINGO CARD.
I CAN'T TELL WHAT HIS LATEST
THINKING IS, BUT WITH A
JOE BIDEN HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
THE SUBPOENA IF IT WAS PROPER?
>> IF YOU DON'T LIKE JOE BIDEN'S
ANSWER, JUST WAIT AN HOUR AND HE
WILL GIVE YOU THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
I FOUND IT DUMBFOUNDING.
HE GUTTED ONE OF HIS TWO
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT WHEN HE
SAID YOU ALL ARE TRYING TO
REMOVE A PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE
FOR DOING WHAT I JUST PROMISED
TO DO ALL THESE DEMOCRATS ARE
SUPPORTING BIDEN, THAT'S THE
EXACT SAME CONDUCT.
HE'S NOT GOING TO COMPLY WITH
THE SUBPOENA WHICH IS ONE OF THE
TWO ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
AGAINST TRUMP IS.
DOES HE HAVE TO COMPLY?
EVEN GO TO COURT.
HE CAN MOVE TO QUASH IT AND HE
CAN EVOKE SOME PRIVILEGE IF HE
HAS ONE THAT HE'S ENTITLED TO
BUT THAT IS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
POSITION.
IF YOU WANT MICK AND BOLTON TO
TESTIFY, THEN TAKE THEM TO COURT
AND HAVE THE THIRD BRANCH ORDER
THEM TO APPEAR BUT SCHIFF IN THE
HOUSE DEMOCRATS DIDN'T WANT TO
DO THAT.
>> Jason: IT'S RICH TO
ACTUALLY HEAR SENATOR SCHUMER
MAKE THE CLAIM THAT THEY NEED A
FAIR TRIAL, THEY NEED THE
DOCUMENTS, THEY NEED WITNESSES.
IN THE HOUSE, THEY DIDN'T GIVE
HIM A CHANCE TO HAVE A MINORITY
WITNESS.
>> IT IS RICH FOR ANY DEMOCRAT
BUT YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE
ALREADY SAID THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING DESPITE THE FACT
THAT NOT A SINGLE PIECE OF
EVIDENCE HAS BEEN INTRODUCED.
HE SAID THE FACTS ARE
UNDISPUTED.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE TRIAL
HAS NOT BEGUN YET.
YOU HAVE HALF A DOZEN MEMBERS OF
THE JURY THAT ARE RUNNING FOR
THE JOB OF THE PERSON THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE SITTING IN
DISPASSIONATE JUDGMENT OF.
YOU WOULD NEVER HAVE THAT IN ANY
REAL, FAIR OR JUDICIAL
PROCEEDING.
THE NOTION THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW
LIKE A COURTROOM WHERE YOU HAVE
12 PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT MADE UP
THEIR MINDS.
JASON, OUT OF 100, GOOD LUCK
FINDING 12 OUT OF A HUNDRED WHO
ARE NOT MADE UP THEIR MINDS.
I CAN THINK OF MAYBE SIX, MAYBE
SIX THAT A FULL BLOWN TRIAL
MIGHT MOVE ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
BUT THE OTHER 94 GOING TO VOTE
THE SAME WAY WHETHER THE TRIAL
ESTATE OR A YEAR FROM NOW.
>> Jason: LET'S GO TO PELOSI
AND THE DELAY.
IF YOU GO BACK AND READ THE
ARTICLES THAT WERE PASSED IN THE
HOUSE, THE DEMOCRATS WROTE THEM.
THEY PASSED THEM ALL BY
THEMSELVES.
IT ALSO SAYS THOSE ARTICLES WILL
BE EXHIBITED TO THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
NANCY PELOSI AS THE SPEAKER HAS
NOT TRANSFERRED THEM OVER.
DOESN'T MATTER IF SHE TRANSFERS
THEM?
B, WHY WOULD YOU DELAY IT THE
WAY SHE IS?
>> I DON'T KNOW, JC, IF HE IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THE
REPUBLIC AND IF WE ARE REALLY
FACED WITH THIS ONCE IN A 200
YEAR ABUSE OF POWER, WHY IN THE
WORLD YOU'D BE SITTING ON THE
INDICTMENT AND NOT SENDING IT
OVER FOR IT TO BE TRIED, IF SHE
WERE A REPUBLICAN SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, I PROMISE YOU SHE WOULD
BE ASKED A LOT MORE ABOUT IT BUT
I HAVEN'T HEARD OR ASKED MUCH IN
THE LAST WEEK.
I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT IT'S ABOUT
THE SENATE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT KEEPING THE HOUSE
BECAUSE I THINK THEY ARE GOING
TO DO IT.
IT'S ABOUT PUTTING A HANDFUL OF
REPUBLICAN SENATORS IN TIGHT
SPOTS IN NOVEMBER.
CORY GARDNER AND TOM TILLERSON
SUSAN COLLINS MARTHA McSALLY.
PUT THEM IN TIGHT SPOTS, MAKE
THEM CAST DIFFICULT VOTES
BECAUSE EVEN WHEN TRUMP IS
REELECTED AND I THINK HE WILL BE
IN THE FALL OF 2020, IF HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE SENATE COME
HE'S GOING TO BE ESSENTIALLY
NEUTERED AS A PRESIDENT IN TERMS
OF GETTING HIS CABINET.
THAT'S ALWAYS WHAT I HAVE
THOUGHT THIS WAS ABOUT
INTERACTIONS TEND TO CONFIRM IT.
>> Jason: IF THEY TRANSFER
THEM, COULD HAPPEN TOMORROW,
COULD HAPPEN NEVER.
IF THEY DO THAT, IS IT
LEGITIMATE TO CALL UP HUNTER
BIDEN OR THE WHISTLE-BLOWER?
DO YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT IN I
DO YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT IN N
DO YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY AND A SENATE
TRIAL?
I WOULD TELL THE REPUBLICANS
DON'T CALL ANY WITNESSES.
IT'S THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS' JOB TO
BUILD A CASE AND THEY COULD'VE
GONE TO COURT AND COMPELLED MICK
TO TESTIFY AND BOLTON.
THEY COULD'VE HONORED DEVIN AND
JOHN RATCLIFFE REQUESTED HUNTER
BIDEN TESTIFY.
THEY DIDN'T DO THAT.
THE INVESTIGATION IS OVER.
THIS IS THE TRIAL PRESENTED ON
THE PAPER, THE DISPENSATIONS,
MAKE YOUR OPENING AND CLOSING
STATEMENTS AND THEN VOTE.
IF THE DRY WOOD SURVEY, THE
PRESIDENT WOULD WIN AND I DON'T
LIKE YOU LOSE A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN SENATOR AND HE MIGHT
PICK UP ON IF YOU HAVE THE JURY
AND YOU KNOW HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO RULE, GO AHEAD AND GET
IT OVER WITH.
THE PRESIDENT CAN SAY WHATEVER
HE WANTS TO AFTER THE TRIAL IS
OVER.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT CALLING
WITNESSES WHEN I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY.
THIS IS NOT A DRAMA THROUGH THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING WHERE WE NEED A
REALLY SPELLBINDING EXCITING
ENDING.
I LIKE NO DRAMA WHEN IT COMES TO
TRIALS.
HE'S GOING TO WIN IF THE VOTERS
TODAY -- LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET
THE VOTE OVER WITH.
>> Jason: I'VE GOT TO ASK YOUR
REAL QUICKLY IN A PARTING
QUESTION HERE ABOUT
PETER STRZOK.
HE MADE ANOTHER COMMENT TODAY
ABOUT HIS FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS
TO TWEET OR SAY OR TEXT WHATEVER
HE WANTS TO SAY AS A FEDERAL
EMPLOYEE.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IF YOU WERE
REALLY CONFIDENT OF HIS
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS, I DON'T
KNOW I WOULD'VE OFFERED TO TAKE
A CUT IN PAY.
YOU AND I'VE A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I REALLY CAN'T GIVE ANYONE WHO'S
DONE MORE DAMAGE TO THE FBI'S
BRAND IN THE LAST 18 MONTHS THAN
PETER STRZOK.
I WILL JUST TELL YOUR VIEWERS,
FOR EVERYONE PETER STRZOK, THERE
ARE 100 FANTASTIC FBI AGENTS.
YOU JUST DON'T KNOW THEIR NAMES.
DON'T JUDGE THAT ENTITY, THAT
AGENCY BY THE PETER STRZOK FOR
LESS OF THE WORLD.
HE IS A ONE OFF.
I'M GLAD HE'S OUT.
HE NEVER SHOULD'VE BEEN
INVESTIGATING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I'M GLAD HE'S OUT OF THE FBI AND
HOPE HE LOSES THE HELL OUT OF